buenas tardes elisabeth born es una
ingeniera de 61 años de la escuela
politécnica prestigiosa escuela de
ingenieros francesa ella ligada en sus
inicios al partido socialista fue por
ejemplo jefa de gabinete de ségolène
royal cuando era ministra de ecología
también fue incluso presidenta de la
empresa de transportes metropolitanos de
parís la atp y durante el gobierno de
manuel macrón ella se acercó a la
republica en marcha el nombre que tenía
el partido del presidente y fue tres
veces ministra de transporte primero
luego de la transición ecológica y
solidaria y luego ministra del trabajo y
del empleo y de la inserción justamente
una de las cosas que hizo allí fueron
muy criticadas fue la reforma del seguro
de cesantía una de las reformas
importantes del ingenio de manuel macro
que quería justamente restringir el
acceso a las ayudas durante su periodo
también como ministra del transporte
abrió a la competencia la empresa de
transportes metropolitanos de parís y la
empresa de trenes la s en cef la empresa
de trenes o ferrocarriles francesa es
una mujer como decíamos tecnócrata con
un perfil muy profesional de eso hablan
los sindicatos por ejemplo que
trabajaron con ella esa reforma del
seguro de desempleo dicen que es una
mujer que escucha que siempre estaba
abierta por ejemplo a responder el
teléfono pero quienes también la conocen
de crítica justamente que quizás tiene
un perfil demasiado técnico en un
momento en que también se necesita una
persona más política en el cargo de
primer ministro angela bien entonces
cuáles eran sus principales retos en
medio de los llamados a esta renovación
por parte de macrón tras su reelección
si renovación recordemos pero también
hay muchos desafíos sociales hay grandes
problemas como la distribución del poder
adquisitivo de los franceses es
justamente uno de los temas que va a
atacar apenas pasen las elecciones
legislativas de junio las legislativas
de junio justamente son un primer
desafío unir a los franceses recordemos
que un tercio del electorado votó por él
y me lanzó en el candidato de la
izquierda va a tener una gran oposición
de izquierda después de esa alianza que
pasaron todos los partidos bajo el
liderazgo de ella melanio no justamente
y el punto más importante y polémico la
reforma de las jubilaciones como
ministra del trabajo conoce muy bien el
tema dice también que por eso eligió el
presidente manuel nación que quería
justamente un tecnócrata en este cargo y
obviamente va a ser un tema complicado
recordemos que el presidente quiere
aumentar a 65 años de edad de jubilación
los dos candidatos que se oponían a él
en las elecciones presidenciales
proponía justamente reducir esa edad a
los 60 años por lo tanto va a ser un
tema complicado en general
las jubilaciones sobre todo y obviamente
como decía yo las elecciones
legislativas en junio unir a la mayoría
y obtener una mayoría fuerte en apoyo al
gobierno de manuel macrón angela
precisamente ayudará a borneo muy
brevemente a erika a contrarrestar este
fuerte apoyo que ha obtenido la francia
insumisa de jianlong como la misión tras
ocupar tercer puesto en las elecciones
de abril
sí sí angela bueno básicamente todos los
líderes políticos de milán son el primer
secretario del partido socialista ha
criticado justamente la gestión de elisa
de borda me gustaría citar el twitter de
jalid melanson que es el que quizás
mejor ejemplifica eso dice disminuyó el
seguro de desempleo a un millón de
personas sin trabajo suprimió la
regulación de las tarifas de gas pospuso
en diez años el fin de la energía
nuclear abrió la competencia a los
trenes y el transporte
el público de parís ya estamos listos
para una nueva temporada de maltrato
social